15 million cases of covid19 in the
united states we've got hospitals
overwhelmed 107 000 people are
in the hospital at this moment doctors
say these numbers are going to keep
getting worse
on wednesday there were more deaths from
covet 19
on one day than there were on september
11th these are pretty big numbers
um that people are looking on at the
situation and and just
appalled at how massively uh covet 19
has expanded throughout the united
states how much the pandemic seems to be
completely out of control
now joe biden is promising that when he
takes office uh he will tackle this
issue
for his first hundred days in office
he's talking about a mask
mandate i'm absolutely convinced that in
100 days we can change the course of the
disease
and change life in america for the
better
i'm going to ask for a masking plan
everyone for the first 100 days of my
administration to wear a mask
it will start with my sign in order on
day one to require
masks where i can under the law there is
some concern
about how a masked mandate would be
enforced around the country
where there are states and localities
that have
mandated masks be worn we've seen kind
of a rebellion among sheriffs and local
police officers who are refusing to
enforce it
for example in california this local
sheriff referred to a mask
mandate as dictatorial he is expecting
us to arrest anyone violating these
orders
site them and take their money close
their businesses
make them stay in their homes and take
away their civil liberties
or he will punish all of us the
riverside county sheriff's department
will not be blackmailed bullied or used
as muscle
against riverside county residents in
the enforcement of the governor's orders
unemployment numbers in the united
states are actually the highest they've
been
since mid-september we had a situation
where this week
853 000 people lost their jobs
bringing the total number of unemployed
to 10.7 million according to
the u.s department of labor now despite
this there is a deadlock in congress
they're fighting over the stimulus
package
there's not a clear agreement between
the two major parties about
how relief should be provided and of
course we've got the two major parties
blaming each other how many more
businesses
have to shutter how many more dreams
have to be shattered
how many more people have to be laid off
before nancy pelosi and the democrats
will act
if we need more time then we take more
time but we have to have a bill
and we cannot go home without it things
are pretty
out of control the rival parties are
blaming each other joe biden is
promising that he will turn things
around
however there's a strong amount of
opposition to the measures he's already
proposing even before he takes office
quite a problematic and serious
situation here in the united states
people were kind of confused about what
exactly to do
uh to protect themselves um you know
also i think many americans
they don't like to be told what to do so
they fought restrictions
and they continue to fight the
restrictions and fight what their
doctors are advising
some of the states are stretched you
know beyond capacity following every
holiday there's
there's a small surge and now it's a
pretty big surge
after thanksgiving there's still a
significant portion of our population
that doesn't
get what's happening